he's practically an original at the
worldwide leader in sports because he
started I think I don't know if who was
there day one or not but we'll ask him
because he's on the phone line right now
he's the general fresh off of his Sports
Emmy win last night best studio host in
all the land and he is richly deserving
of that Bob Lee of outside the lines in
the worldwide leader how are you Bob
just fine rich thank you actually if
you're scoring at home and don't you
think you want to be just day three 1973
yeah rather biblical so you're you're a
third day you're a third you're a third
dare I mean exactly
yeah that's unbelievable on that place
and just look around and just go well I
can't believe it looks like this now Bob
yeah but you know what and you spent
enough time there to ingest this part of
the culture for sure that you're usually
so busy doing stuff yeah there's not a
lot of time for reflection unless of
course we're printing in front of a
mirror I said well I usually reflected
on how big this place is gotten when I
was looking for a parking spot Bob tell
me the parking situation is improved as
it has but for reasons we can't get into
okay okay very good
all right good do you still do you still
have the same personalized plate Bob I
won't say it on the air but you still
have to say I appreciate that one of my
colleagues did and he's still recovering
from his wounds yes I still do it's
unbelievable that is very well on the
same car which is come on you don't have
the same car you don't have the same car
yes it's a classic just like yourself
Bob let's put it that way
so öto and what you guys do every day
and what you spearhead every day seems
to be more and more an outlier in our
business Bob
why do you keep doing what you're doing
every day
well it's challenged on its best days
it's a hell of a lot of fun I work with
some incredibly talented and energetic
and and just impressive people and it
because it's it's stuff that needs to be
done and I sort of addressed that last
night in my remarks
I mean it's it's a complicated sports
world that we're in both the financial
challenge different platforms I mean if
it doesn't fit on your phone it really
doesn't have any future value there
paywalls going up there are different
platforms emerging there are so many
different business relationships between
entities and rights holders and
platforms it's a challenge and there but
it just creates more and more areas that
need to be in questions that need to be
asked and then fairly answered and
everyone gets a chance at the table not
to go all Network on you from from the
movie days I am mad at help by the way I
know you know the whole thing I'm sure
but now and certainly I'm I've lived
this for 15 years now networks are
sometimes owned by sports leagues and
sometimes networks are in business with
sports leagues and thus there might be
some sort of conversation about what to
cover and what not to cover do you hear
more of that at all at ESPN or do they
truly just let you do whatever you are
going to do in your rundown meetings and
go ahead click them I'm not so I would I
don't want to say the word naive I and
it's not so it's not that simplistic and
we've all seen reporting on these these
issues in fact including specifics
regarding our show in the network in
recent months but I will tell you at the
the area that I work and with the folks
that I work at know it's we're smart
enough to like to think we're smart
enough to do what we do with an open
mind fairly and with invitations to all
be part of the conversation if there are
other conversations of other levels let
them take place but the proof is in the
pudding and the pudding is on one
o'clock every day Eastern Time 10:00
a.m. Pacific time there you go that's
right 2018 waiting into a promo look Bob
there's no I and Bob or Lee you're a
team player you're a team player
you know or ESPN I'm out at 2018 sports
any outstanding sports personality
studio host winner Bob Lee here on the
Rich Eisen show I think I know what the
answer to the question is but I'll ask
it anyway the most important story that
you've been covering on OTL is what oh
my gosh
over the years and I mean we were in the
year 2000 beginning to report on brain
injuries and its impact and athletes and
concussions and issues I think I can't
say one I can certainly that has been a
hallmark I think we've uh by the way I
think you know from the year 2000 I can
point back to them a straight line of it
court reported their leagues and
athletes in just the science I also
think the area of hazing we've done some
very important work and how about
recently then how about recently then
just this past recently I I'm very proud
of what all of ESPN has done and the
various platforms and we've tried to
include everybody in the reporting I'm a
social activism and the issues facing
the National Football League and then
what they the so called and they're not
anthem protests their protest during the
end of their gestures other people the
players coalition feels strongly that
that term misstates what they're trying
to say but I will put what we've been
able to report and the parties we've
reported to the analysis the questions
we raised up against anybody's reporting
in that area including the fissures in
the players area the challenges facing
Roger Goodell and the owners and down to
what's going to happen later this month
it may at the other's media we're gonna
have a balkanization of different rules
in the league that's it it's important
question because it's an emotional
question involves the anthem it involves
football which matters to so many people
and then bounce politics down to the
White House so where do things stand
with your outside the lines reporting
with Michigan State and dr. Larry Nasser
well yeah I mean bridge we've been on
that story John Barr is like much is
reporting for over a year on the issue
of sexual abuse masters role in that as
well as a report that last fall on
Michigan State's administration and
their demonstrated history of concern or
lack thereof towards sexual assault
allegations involving athletes in those
two stories sort of coalesced late last
year and I honestly believe when we look
back in another 10 15 20 years and not
just what OTL in e60 of reported or
sports centered but what all the sports
entities have looked at the issues
had been on the table I think the Larry
master story he will have a unique place
in hell and this story will have a
unique place in our culture it may
actually outshine the is equally
important in the era now me to move with
master did it's just it's beyond words
beyond words do you miss the toy
department part of us Bob Lee I mean
doing highlights the old you mentioned
Sports Center that's my first memory of
meeting you well you had that the desk
at the 6:00 p.m. Eastern Sports Center
off to the side with Robin Roberts and
Charlie on the main desk and you off to
decide what we called the general store
since you were generally and you know I
mean do you miss that doing that not not
a PC nickname by the way well I thought
it was always the car I always thought
it was the car from the exactly besides
bestowed on I may not claim but I'm not
excusing it you know it I've been
fortunate to be part of a lot of our
soccer coverage and and I mean with what
I've been privileged to be part of in
the 2010 World Cup the 2014 World Cup
2011 Women's World Cup in Germany and
just two years ago spending the summer
in France for the European Championships
you got a lot of year you're itching
down there of highlights of competition
and you're in the moment and you're in
the culture that revels in it so now I
had my chance to keep my handed I'm just
talking about you know when you first
started day three the we are family
Pirates were getting set to take on the
Orioles later on that fall you know like
I'm talking about getting in a Sports
Center doing highlights to minute to
minute highlights on a baseball game or
something like that
well you're not tell you in the
beginning all we had were highlights
from three or four teams off the cable
box I mean there weren't as many
highlights as you might want to think
early on they wouldn't end it was a
while before we could start snatching
them out of the air off of satellites
you know listen do it doing a late night
SportsCenter your adrenalin runs at a
level of no to you know I've made maybe
jet fighter pilots but you know you know
what it's like to you know you reach out
your hand but you're on the air and
you're right reading the lead-in to a
highlight you don't have highlights you
have the strategies for the highlights
you feel a piece of paper pressed in
your hand
they take the tape you halt the the
writings light you bowling you're off I
mean that's yes that's the fun part of
this business and hey we got you know
George Steinbrenner's agreed to do the
at the live shot we got them in three
minutes won't get ready with your
questions that's the fun part that is
that really really is in hey Bob it's
fun hearing somebody that's so richly
deserve an Emmy getting one last night
like you did for real how rich I really
appreciated you you are among the first
to reach out to text back I really
appreciate it and I treasured the time
we work David yeah me too so you're
going to spend time with family today so
what you got going on yeah exactly
time to the city and then that climb
back on the pumpkin cart and head back
up to the country you are the last one
for you then who do you think wins the
World Cup this year give it to me what
do you got for me it's an iguana when I
would like me to be Belgium they've got
the talent they've got the manager good
friend and you know the English can
chill down yeah it will be the English I
mean you just an ordinary footballing
nation we know it's not going to be
italy remember well of course if it
comes down to referee calls and tight
matches we know it will be Russia for
obviously but that's on a future outside
the lines I imagine when they exactly
and then one done under take care of Bob
Congrats again the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience